foreign
[Music]
Harbor in Southern California an
Oceanfront playground that attracts
throngs of tourists and locals it's this
ideal location that Drew Mikey
michelados and his wife Lynn to open a
Greek restaurant just Steps From the
water
hello welcome to the Greek from day one
when we opened the restaurant in 1994 it
was a success oh my gosh it's really
good we did great it was always busy
already guys let's starting my dad he
had that old school Greek work mentality
just go go go go and the kitchen was
always running very smoothly I need a
large pen because I'm going to cook some
onion I felt my American dream come
through make me feel like very
successful very very good
But as time went on
my dad's standards have dropped okay I
got a complaint guys they said the chef
tethers were rock hard he's been working
365 days a year for 17 years he's just
burning out from being here so long it
was rubbery what do you mean robbery
I don't know there's no robbery monkey I
mean he hardly anymore is making sure
that everything is cooked to Perfection
that sounds good it hurts me when I see
our level drop because the standards are
not high enough I'm done
lamb is very dry
[Laughter]
Mikey's really let a lot of things slip
through the cracks the calamari was
really really I taste the calamari it
was good well it's not like it okay and
that's why our business has declined
[Music]
very many people around the situation is
frustrating but I want to change this
place I want to make it better I haven't
learned everything but I will I know I
can I mean I'm very capable and I know I
can make it better than ever
my dad has a hard time listening to
other people sometimes because this is
what he created but I'm here to help I
mean he wants to make sure I'm 100 ready
but I can't be 100 ready if he doesn't
allow me to be I need your help
he's a great Entertainer great people
person
but at the same time how are you going
to help me run a restaurant if you don't
know the kitchen
to run this restaurant you have to come
back here at this kitchen and Aries you
know have done this before
[Music]
this restaurant is not only my father's
Legacy it's all of our Legacy we've all
worked together and I've seen the profit
pretty much diminished until it's been
non-existent how much money do we have
in our account right now we're getting
low we're getting low I don't know how
I'm gonna do this
it's like we work our asses off and we
don't make any money it's
word
oh my God I'm just hoping that Chef
Ramsay will help us get this restaurant
to be the success it deserves to be
I don't want what we've spent years
building up
fast
I just don't want that to happen
[Music]
wow look at this place absolutely
stunning on the water it's almost like a
little slice of the Mediterranean I'm
fairly busy as well how on Earth can a
restaurant fail in this spot time to
find out what's been going on
it's huge great food on the water
hello
well hello how are you I'm excellent my
first name is yeah Lynn Lynn Gordon nice
to see you um owner yeah
you're running with your husband
hello hi nice to meet you
I'm not sure why don't you get your
father let's sit down and catch up I'm
really happy to see Chef Ramsay and I
hope he's pretty nice to my voice
not too nice
okay
um I am very happy to be here B I'm
dying to find out what's wrong with the
place How could a restaurant not work
when it's sat on the water
nice okay mum
uh 17 years it was very successful and
we did very very well so when did it
start to turn the last couple of years
not profitable yeah wow okay
um and how often are you here when I
work 14 hours a day seven days a week
but seven days a week yeah that's a true
serious that's crazy it is crazy he's
been doing it too long he's burnt down
and he might not admit it but he is are
you in downtown no no no no you're gonna
sit in that kitchen till you drop I mean
where's the succession there's the goal
to groom Iris would take over or no no
well I'm here and I'm doing all the a
lot of stuff right now I mean sure do
you work in the kitchen I don't but
that's one of my goals I want to learn
the kitchen it's one of my I'm glad
you're here because I want to learn more
stuff and did you teach him how to cook
no ready what
is he not good enough
are you that much of a control freak no
no no no
is he not committed I feel like I'm
pulling teeth here back in my mind I
expect him to be more here than he was
so he's not committed he is getting the
passion he never really wanted when he
graduated I never thought I would do he
didn't want to be part of our business
well I mean I'm here just trying to save
this place and it's just are you
committed now I am committed here I am
you are yes I am
[Music]
I understand like yeah I haven't been
here at times but I need Chef Ramsay to
prove to my dad that I'm ready to do
whatever it takes to make this place run
better and smoothly and it's time for
big changes this is the time
so how would you rate your food out of
10 what would you give it my food I give
it 10 10 yes right let me eat let me uh
get the grips good to see you nice to
meet you likewise and um okay all the
recipes that I have for the Greek food
came from Greece a lot of people when
they visit Greece they come here and
they tell me the food is better here
than Greece I think Sir Francis is gonna
like my food yes
and this restaurant almost 15. wow wow
wow so you know everything everything
first the calamari the calamari is going
to be heaven what's going to be how
exactly [__] okay let's try the calamari
okay and you know what I'll have the uh
Hot Stuff the platter the plateau okay
and I'll take the cold pattern as well
I'd like to see that I want to see as
much as possible okay anything else I'll
have the masaka beef yeah with the beef
Brilliance I think we're done thank you
I'm very excited San Francis
he needs to see when the food is not
good and everything is not good
calamari appetizer make it
hit the olive oil and put onions and
bell peppers with the wine you guys do
what I said Mike is a very proud person
he does not take criticism well but Jeff
Ramsey is here to help he's not here to
compliment
hmm nice tables why would you cover them
table cloths
the deck always hideous
I haven't seen chairs like this
since they're bankrupt 30 years ago my
grandma's 80th
just got ball up there Saturday Night
Fever
in fact it's like there's two disco
balls up there what's going on
it's like going back to 1970.
okay that that's like a limo okay
heaven or hell
oh dear and this is our Coldplay okay
okay great thank you thank you
reason
it looks like I'm having a hell day
right yeah it's not yeah it's not it's
not good yeah
it's terrible
can I take it away quickly I know
[Music]
it is very popular
that's a strange looking hummus
seriously no the only way to do that is
this straw
Greek dips it looks like six plates of
Greek dog [__] that's what it goes in
like imagine what's going to come out
like my game
I mean you have to be really idiot to
make the hummus watery
this is our hot sampler wow okay Jesus
meatballs are cold in the middle
Falafel look like they've been sat on
my [__] Greek goddess yeah no and the
Philippines a lot of filo paste but
hardly anything in them yeah they're in
Greasy very shiny yeah not good they're
terrible there's no filling in there
thank you thank you
the taste of Grease yeah tasted greasy
[Music]
what the [__] is that what is that this
is
that's for The Roasted uh potatoes okay
great thank you thank you I enjoy it
well soccer
strap him is shocking so bad
Dreadful
Dimitri
the eggplant is spongy and raw you're
having the musaka yeah it's disgusting
carrots and mush that is an insult to
any Greek aisle listen can you get me
all the chefs in the kitchen out on the
Dance Floor I'd like to meet them please
okay guys all of the cooks he want them
over there he wants all the cook
everybody
[Music]
I mean Falafel sucks to me it wasn't
good I saw some of my foot is not the
way he was describing the food oh dear
dear oh dear I do that
was a disaster
I mean I've just sat down and had the
biggest [__] embarrassment to Greece
that I've ever tasted in my entire life
the platter Bland Falafel dry and the
biggest kick in my Greek Johannes liquid
hummus
liquids
the Greek moussaka eggplant undercooked
bitter there's an insult not just the
grease but to the vegetable itself did
anyone taste it of course it's wrong
it's done wrong come on that's
frightening what hurts me is the fact
you're actually realizing that it's [__]
and still sending it I can't do anything
about it
I'm Greek I grew up with this suit but
I'm not allowed to cook the food the way
I'm cooked in Greece here I'm following
my kids way and he's tired Mikey have
you given up no you run your business
like you've given up no no it's not true
I don't believe that my food is that
terrible okay my food is similar
kefalonia do you think it's similar to
Catalonia yes sir yeah not today my
friend your calamari is greasy it's
bland how come I have all these people
says my Kalama is the best I ever have
the blowing smoke up your ass you're not
that stupid
thousands of people no stop exaggerating
where are the thousands of people that
tell you that your calamari is the best
are they booked in for dinner tonight
[Music]
you came from Greece you bring it over
you make it better here
we've made it worse
I get really upset when Seth Ramses talk
to me like that I know how that food is
and the people love it and he has no
clue about the food here
[Music]
the town of Ventura is a buzz with Chef
Ramsay's visit how y'all doing and as
the restaurant fills up with diners are
you ready
Chef Ramsay is anxious to begin his
kitchen investigation during dinner
service so what are you doing service
how do you work what do you do what I do
here yeah yeah
I watch
I watch a new expedites I do if I have
to wow what are the TOs systems POS it's
right here Marika Marika there's my
daughter right there hello Hi how are
you nice to meet you good to see you too
I think Chef Ramsey doesn't know what
he's stepping into my dad is just like
really set in his ways
and what's that for just the men's
onions and this is vegetables baked
carrots
and just take out whatever is for the
order each order that's not good but I'm
not leading the kitchen so I don't
really have a saying over there it's
always cooked it's cooking right now
yeah no it's not cooking it's cooked
yeah we're cooking food and it's it's
sitting there drying out it's all cooked
to [__] it doesn't look like a cafeteria
to you no God bless California
[Music]
with so much of the food prepared in
advance are you happy with that yes this
restaurant has no problem sending dishes
out at a rapid Pace hey about 10 table
15 table 91 please ready
calamari chicken caesar salad
this food normally come out this quick
lately yeah it's like sort of flying out
okay it's running take it take it oh my
gosh Mikey do not tell them anything
you're saying it to the chefs what do
you want me to say
keep going everything all right back
here get them out
it's just ridiculous like I'm not trying
to stop you I'm trying to help you but
my dad he gets so egotistical about it
sometimes it's like I'm just this little
eight-year-old getting barked at
your arms yeah yeah I just need to cool
off after that oh no no I can see the
tension
your father's there Expediting the food
letting it go sauce dripping all over
the side and it's almost like he's given
up I mean was he like that 10 years ago
no I think he's just physically
exhausted and he's been working 15 hours
a day his whole life I mean imagine that
do you ever sit down and say dad you
know it's so obvious where we're going
wrong and I want to help but he doesn't
want to listen he's so stubborn man
I don't know man it's just
horrific this has turned out to be a
very funny Greek restaurant a little bit
different than what I expected
unfortunately for the diners the
restaurant is also different from what
they expected
more and they were still raw oh God
as Trey this is cold after Trey the lamb
chops are supposed to be rare after Trey
Blood gets sent back to the kitchen oh
my God unbelievably there's almost as
much food coming back as there is going
out
Dad how you doing don't bother me go
dance go dance
the situation is frustrating obviously
if we have problems with this restaurant
but I don't know what to do exactly you
ready huh yeah I'll announce it right
now hello everybody Welcome to the Greek
at the harbor my name is Eris uh we're
gonna perform a little dancing for you
right now so please enjoy the show
there's more dances to come
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
what's that cleft thing going on Greek
dancing and the belly dancing and really
yeah
[Music]
I'm [__] believable
[Applause]
[Music]
now I get what he's passionate about
[Applause]
finally something edible
despite Eris pleasing some of the diners
with his dancing
[Music]
they continue to be far from pleased
with the food
the batter on the fish and chips was
still slimy the roast lamb was inedible
give me Aries please oh and they said
all of it was lukewarm where's Mike what
is it to smell that just not inside
there inside what's wrong with that eat
a little bit I'm not eating nice smell
yes it's what it's good you're sick Mike
you're sick man I'm very worried about
Mikey because it should be obvious when
something's not cooked properly there's
no way that you can say oh well they
were just complainers it's real Harris
you need to know what's going on here as
well as far as your father's concerned
it's good there's nothing wrong with it
let's try yourself he's not even a chef
and he knows it's dry come on Mike you
stood down and watch that [__] come out
it's an embarrassment the Catalonia
I knew this was going to happen my dad
he's not stupid he's a great cook but he
also isn't denial bit he's the type of
person like asking for help maybe is a
sense of failure to him
my emotions are deeply hurt
from what Seth Ramsay says
hey
are you just relaxing yeah it's just
really sad you know
just an older man that
can't really handle it all I love you
amazing
I just don't like it when my dad is so
sad
[Music]
it's an hour and a half into dinner
service they don't like any of it and
even though food is flooding back to the
kitchen you stood down and watched that
[__] come out it's an embarrassment to
Catalonia Mikey seems to have lost
interest
it's almost like he doesn't it's just
what do you want me to say I don't feel
good wearing Seafood tell me about my
yeah
what's happening I don't know but why
are you doing this to yourself what do
you want me to do I want you to wake up
a little bit you're letting it happen
under your nose what do you know I'm
just saying something to be a little bit
more [__] honest with yourself and
never lie okay but how come you haven't
taught Harris anything how can we have
nothing by your side why haven't you
treated him like a son what is it none
of things
Something's Happened and you better tell
me what
I don't know yes you do
I don't have to say nothing
don't act like that you can't just give
up
come on
how we doing
no we're not doing well we're not doing
well it has to be a little bit more
honest with us I'm not honest no you're
paying the price for it I don't
understand why you're not closer to your
father I don't understand why you're not
open with that big Greek heart of yours
I I I don't get it it's time to change
you know
it's gonna need a commitment from you
a commitment and his father son and if
you've got any chance of carrying on
this Legacy then you need to be by his
side you won't teach me with anything it
doesn't make sense
have a word with him have a word I'm
struggling
[__] me
I didn't sit down man
tired
I don't want you to struggle here
anymore
I'm fine dad
just let me let me let me help
let me help you I want you to be ready I
told you that before us I know it was my
dad even though he loves me and I love
him it's just it's almost like I'm not
good enough for him
it's a shitty feeling it hurts
I love you
[Music]
Gordon is still completely mystified by
Mikey's lack of mentoring of Eris you've
got two minutes we'll catch up okay
please Annie is only one other person to
turn to for answers so I'd love to hear
from you you know why have they been
ignoring each other
well when heiress went to college he
never really wanted to be here and most
of the time he wouldn't be here at all
he'd come like at night to dance and so
forth and when he graduated from college
we had his party here so we had I mean
the place was full we had 100 people
here so and when he was doing his little
speech and thanking people for coming
and everything you know he announced
I'm gonna make something of my life I'm
not working in the restaurant what in
front of all the stuff in front of all
of his friends
wow I mean how rude you paid the fees
for the college it comes back and hosts
the party in his parents restaurants and
then shits on them from a great height
I remember that
very well
that was as if what we've done all these
years was like uh worthless
is Mikey sort of hers do you think he
still holds it against him yeah does he
yeah it's he really does
unbelievable
it hurt us
very bad
[Music]
I've always remembered it I've never
discussed it never talked about it
but it hurt
Gordon has finally learned the real
truth behind what's tearing this family
apart he announced I'm gonna make
something of my life I'm not working in
the restaurant what
and now Mike and Eris arrive at the
restaurant unaware of what he has just
uncovered please
I want to tell you something really
important
I'm [__] up with you and I'll tell you
why I don't think that you've quite
understood the level of support that
you've had in and out of here and so
when you turn around and told all your
friends and your parents restaurant that
you're gonna make something out yourself
almost in a way that you are disgusted
with being brought up in a restaurant
and this wasn't you you were above that
well it wasn't me being above it it was
just I didn't know if it was the way you
declared it wasn't good enough for you
well this was before I know yes but you
did it and you shat on your own doorstep
I wasn't sitting on that I love my
family I'm telling you you did
well I was I was confused at the time
too I didn't know what I was going to do
with my life I went to college I didn't
know if the restaurant business was
something I was going to do and I didn't
know if I was ready to do it but I don't
think you've ever understood the
ramifications of a announcement like
that how did you feel truly about that
statement my son when I say something
like that it hurts me yeah thank you
I mean I I'm not perfect no I'm just
saying look no no if you've got anything
to say yeah I'd say to your mom and dad
take the opportunity to give a little
bit of privacy
I
[Music]
I just see how we struggle as a family
regardless if we're making money or not
we we kill ourselves here and I didn't
want to kill myself either not in a
selfish way I just didn't want to I
don't
know but I guess I remember it because
it really hurt me when you said it I
remember it and I don't think there's
anything that we've ever talked about
and I sincerely apologize for saying
that because that was so wrong of me
Mom Dad I'm sorry
yeah I love you too I think Mikey hasn't
really taken era seriously because he's
never really gotten himself committed
but that has changed and for him to make
this declaration with such passion he's
definitely committed I 100 believe that
everything's gonna work
as well
[Music]
after heiress cleared the air with his
parents Chef Ramsay is still concerned
about his commitment okay
so I've been doing some thinking why are
you hung around so long it's my family
it's like I don't we don't give up on a
family and this is my my home too so I
love this place and I want to fix it but
I don't know if you're committed enough
that's all because it's not about
dancing on the dance floor but if you
put that determination that you put on
that [__] Dance Floor last night
carrying all those [__] tables in
your mouth in the kitchen trust me
you'll be Untouchable here that's what I
want I know at one point I wouldn't
believe to me either I've changed I know
I can do this I just need support and I
just need my dad would help me
so you say you're committed I am
committed yes and you say that you're
committed yes yes so put both your hands
together
let go
now
oh [__] yep even if I'm right-handed
don't care don't care because you're not
cooking you're gonna be taught
now look at me
for the very first time in the history
of Father and Son get into that kitchen
and show him something I don't care if
it's a simple Greek salad a roasted
fresh or whether it's a stunning hummus
I don't care but show him yeah now
[Music]
why don't pull me too much now don't be
a bull getting handcuffed was a funny
experience I'm gonna need a plate to put
it in all right we're about to walk with
you my dad kind of like this bull trying
to attract me let's make a pasta you
want pasta this is exactly what I've
been looking for to have this
opportunity so let's do it okay slice
the Tomato yeah I can do it
how's that good okay let's put the
onions
[Music]
we're gonna wait on the garlic right
yeah if it cooks faster any seasonings
that we put in or anything let's put
some black pepper a little sprinkle yeah
yeah you want me to add some of the
sauce yeah
cooking with my dad was great reducing a
little bit and then we're done it really
alleviated a lot of tension and I'm
proving them right now I'm gonna learn
the kitchen and I guess the only way you
could ever learn is just to do it right
it's pretty good huh very good tastes
great
totally it was a lot of fun for me and
Harris to be that way and I see that
Aries as a passionate about this
restaurant and I'm very proud Gordon we
got it done show me
what is that Greek pasta did you listen
to your father I did yeah
how is that oh yeah it's nice I've seen
more consistency in this plate than I
did in the whole of service last night
it did my heart good because this was a
turning point this was the first time
that Mikey has ever
really shown Eric any Greek cooking
thank you I have very strong feelings
about my boy that he's not a boy any
longer he's a man and I'm ready to back
off a little out of the way his way are
you committed to do it of course yeah
what I know I would teach you everything
okay okay so that's what I want
[Music]
now that it appears as though Mikey is
finally passing the torch to Eris Chef
Ramsay and his team move ahead with the
restaurant makeover
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
ready for a stunning new change yeah
good today we are saying goodbye to the
Past
and opening the doors to your new future
ready to see a restaurant off you go
going going
wow
welcome to the new Greek
nice it's amazing wow it's so beautiful
it's so beautiful when I first walked in
here I saw a banquet hall with Hideous
chairs that was set up with no charm so
we've taken a tacky restaurant out of
the 80s and put it into the 21st century
and the good news is the disco balls
have gone look at the ceiling you've got
the Greek windmills oh look at that have
a look at those beautiful tables they
were covered before we got them sanded
we got them varnished they're your own
tables excellent gone are the murals why
have a mural of a harbor on the wall
when you're sat in front of the harbor
and look at that baby down there on the
wall a custom-made Greek flag shutter
wow beautiful oh shutter wow this is
outstanding complete Joy that's what I
feel right now
wow oh Jesus how are you huh wow I have
a goosebab on me feels totally like
where I am now in Santorini on the hill
there feels like home is particularly
beautiful Mikey I'd like to see you stay
alive like this aren't you happy yes
yeah I think this is one of your best so
decorations I ever seen
this is
I agree I think it's one of the best
also
to go along with a dramatic makeover
come down all of you please wow it's an
equally dramatic redesign of the menu
okay let's have a look at the menu the
dips Tzatziki the hummus beautiful not
smeared on a plate not sipped through a
straw a proper dip fluffle look at them
small dainty delicious and made with a
spicy chickpea nice gyro it's a homemade
Pate okay wait to taste it you've got
the grilled lamb chop let's see if we
grilled artichokes sun-dried tomatoes
yeah Aruba salad and tazini sauce the
zucchini eggplant moussaka layered with
potatoes topped with Bechamel a little
chilly in there so we've got some heat
in there as well at the same time
excited oh yeah this is the best I ever
seen in my life it's fresh it's taken
part of what you put into this
restaurant to begin with and we've
modernized it that's all you did great
yeah yeah okay I want you all to dig in
all right have a little taste Okay jump
in
oh my God it's amazing excellent at the
beginning actually I where I was I was
denial about the food but this is the
best food I ever have Greek food so good
the Waffle's gone melts in your mouth
not dry the food's really really good I
mean it's amazing it's a new Direction
it's a new beginning and I'm excited
about it this is really tastes good it's
really good
[Music]
um
with the reins of the restaurant being
handed over from father to son okay
Mikey hi you ready great yeah Chef
Ramsay is Mikey working the salad
station and heiress in The crucial role
of expediter you ready yes okay guys you
don't take [__] from them yeah and
you're the last [__] line of defense
don't let them throw food out at you we
have a new menu in line awesome new
recipes I'm taking charge of this
kitchen I want to make sure people are
following the recipes and they're not
[__] them up make me proud boys let's
do this
hello word of the relaunch's spread and
the restaurant fills up quickly with
eager diners hello how you doing you're
welcome to the degree
[Music]
okay
my kitchen needs to be driven let's go
all right first pick it up guys two
vegetarian Musa cars fire those right
away okay final let me count that two
zucchini musakas please areas is in
charge of the kitchen tonight but he has
to step up and and do this I got the
hummus you guys got the Musa cost not
much time two and a half minutes nice
all right another ticket up we got a
shrimp and a calamari all right I got it
how much time on that calamari two
minutes two minutes let's do it cheers
that's what I want to hear push and
encourage push and encourage yeah the
vegetables
in spite of it being his first time
Expediting Kathy you're up to come right
back heiress is looking very comfortable
four minutes on the saganaki watch the
Falafel and a steady stream of orders
are flowing out of the kitchen we got
the Greek salad you should calamari and
the results are unanimous
[Music]
back in the kitchen under the watchful
eye of Chef Ramsay what's the sauce put
Less in there next time yeah I don't
want it all pissing down the side yes
heiress continues to perform
okay I'll [__] go crazy at them
let's go to table 11 here now ready
yes I got one more spot Incorporated
right all right Kelsey you got another
Branzino another Fisherman's catch here
there you go all right who's this for
Kathy just take it is that cooked all
right
still cold it's raw stop stop stop stop
it's relaunch night Harris's big chance
to finally prove himself guys let's get
it together we got it come on but just
when it appears as though everything is
on track here's this for Kathy just take
it the kitchen is starting to unravel is
that cooked let's roll stop stop stop
look at me if they're out of control and
you're out of control we're finished
because you are maintaining the
standards hey hey all of you stop one
two three four five you come here come
here come here look at what you're
sending out that wasn't like the first
table
I'm not sending that and what the [__]
is that come on guys smash look at me
look at me you have to stay in control
you've got to stay in control okay I
can't let the kitchen fall apart I'll do
whatever it takes to get better let's
slow it down slow down slow down thank
you kick it at a time
all right table 32 how we looking and
where's the fisherman's catch I don't
want to see [__] go out guys come on
make sure it's cooked and good all right
a very determined heiress clearly has
his Focus back this chicken sit here too
[__] long finally he's catching
mistakes
that you asked for
[__] cold in the center guys come on
and quickly getting them fixed almost
you're gonna have to reheat this let's
get that done before we continue guys
make sure it's quality listen to him
again stop throwing food well spotted
look at me this is transition this is it
yes okay guys this is a team effort all
right you guys with me yes okay good you
guys got it okay come on good that's
what I want to hear
awesome Ozzy take this keep it going
guys we need a little bit more sauce on
that meat nice I need one more calamari
guys coming thank you
fire the chicken fire the lamb chops
yeah let's focus on table 25 and table
30. doing good can you believe that
system no oh a surprise a little bit but
Ayers did a great job for the first time
Expediting just wipe it down I'm very
proud of myself
oh my gosh so how do you guys like the
new menu
that's awesome good they loved it not
one complaint I just need the lamb
burger and we're done coming up now
let's finish this [__] come on Eric is
totally in control of the line
Expediting and table by table by table
he's stepped up so good what's good
and that's a fabulous feeling
[Laughter]
well done seriously well done we had an
excellent relaunch yes we had our bums
but my god there was an amazing buzz in
there tonight a dramatic change yes yeah
because we love the food yeah love the
decor but the big transformation tonight
was Iris
you nailed it you did a phenomenal job
thank you I've never seen anyone
and I really mean this take to
Expediting the way you did tonight that
was your first time and it felt like
you've been doing it for 10 years Mikey
how was that for you to listen to him
controlling the kitchen he did a great
job it's very impressive
Seth Ramsey came and unite us together
my son and I would be very successful I
believe that stay together as a family
because when it works it's beautiful of
course this family right here we're
unbreakable thank you stay in there I
will yeah look after him thank you very
much because of Chef Ramsay my dad
Believes In Me and he knows I can do
anything I have a lot of work to do
personally to learn the kitchen but I'm
an ambitious young man and I'm ready to
do it you've got the win in the sale run
with it okay thanks again good night
thank you Gordon
[Music]
wow when I first arrived this restaurant
was a big fat Greek mess we made a lot
of changes some dramatic changes to the
food the decor but more importantly to
Aris and now that guy has his feet
firmly on the ground this restaurant has
every chance of not becoming a Greek
tragedy
[Music]
what the [__] was he doing with those
tables
[Music]
in the days that followed heiress
continued to embrace his role as leader
of the kitchen go ahead it out 33 is
next guys I need a vegetarian and is
determined to maintain the high
standards that Chef Ramsay put in place
hey the fish is wrong guys watch the
fish with heiress in complete control
and new customers packing the restaurant
on a nightly basis I love it Mikey is
considering doing something he thought
he would never do it's good to chase
yeah
that's higher Mikey is so proud of her
to make this restaurant be the best it
can be fries let's do it Chef Ramsey
thank you so much Eric's future is
definitely bright and so is the Greeks
great job I love you all
[Music]
foreign